The quest to understand the laws of nature,
at the deepest possible level has been maybe
one of the noblest and most consequential
aspirations of human beings for centuries
now. And in fundamental physics we’ve understood
that to do this we have to go to the extremes,
so we study the laws of nature — what the
universe looks like on the longest possible
distances, the largest possible distances
in cosmology. But also at the very very smallest
possible distances, where we discover that
matter is made up out of elementary particles
that interact with each other governed by
fundamental forces. And rather surprisingly
and very importantly, in the last hundred
years we’ve learned that what seems to be
a dizzying array of very different phenomenon
turn out to be much more closely related to
each other than would appear at first sight.
And that the essential simplicity and unity
and really beauty of the laws of nature only
reveal themselves when you study nature under
a microscope and you look at what’s happening
at very short distances or at very high energies.
So we’ve been going to this short distance
frontier, high energy frontier, for a century
now and there’s absolutely no reason to
stop. In fact, a machine very similar to the
machine that’s being talked about now was
being entertained in the United States already
in the early 1990s — a super conducting
super collider. The U.S., tragically, decided
not to proceed with that project, but it’s
something we know how to do. The technology
exists. The know-how exists. And the scale
of resources that we’re talking about is
not beyond the pale of similar projects in
the past. So that’s the big picture answer
to this question. We need to build this collider
because we can and because it represents the
frontier of what we’ve been doing and studying
the fundamental laws of physics for centuries now.